foreign
[Music]
talk to JC what's up JC
hi hi what's up
hey so I have a question
um my husband is a youth pastor
and no that's all you need to say uh
just want to sit in silence for a while
um and
I have just been I mean we both have
been but
I have just been
verbally abused like just attacked at
churches recently
um and I just want to know like the
church where y'all attend and where he
works
yeah where he worked he just
of uh resignation okay
um but it was just it was just so bad
that
um and we still obviously want to do
ministry because our hearts are in it
but it's just like
how do we when this is like what I think
this is like the third church that has
just hurt us so bad
um and I guess I just want like help
knowing how to like move forward from it
all um
because it's a lot
um
yeah I don't churches can be brutal
right
yeah yeah it was um I don't know if you
want me to go into detail now I'm not
really sure how the process works but
you can but here's the thing
um
I don't know that it's instructive I
don't know I don't I'll say it this way
it does matter what they did and what
they said
I don't think it matters for what I'm
going to tell you okay okay
two things here that I want you and your
husband to spend some time reflecting on
okay
one is the common denominator
denominator the common denominator
Factor okay
okay there's a common denominator factor
that all of these were churches who have
hurt you all these were people inside of
churches that hurt you
yeah there's also a common denominator
Factor
that is y'all too
and so I think it's wise
for you both to spend some time before
you go join another Community a church
Community much less work at one
to ask yourself what are we bringing to
this equation that might be contributing
to something
that's a fair question for you to ask
similar to if somebody calls and says I
just keep getting dumped and keep
getting dumped and keep getting dumped
at some point it's not all their faults
I always want to know like what do you
bring into this dating table well I'm
kind of like this and I kind of
and so I want you to be honest about
what y'all do individually and
collectively bring
to a church community
right you might find nothing
or you might find and you know that's
not true of course you bring stuff but
also you might
um just be around you have to be honest
that this particular Heritage this
particular Faith tradition isn't for us
anymore we've grown we're over here we
keep going to our the faith tradition
that makes us the most comfortable
expecting them to be way down the road
where we are now and we get mad that
they're not and we get mad they get mad
that we're mad who whatever the story is
you have to be honest about where you
are okay
the second thing is
Ministry does not have to be done at a
full-time church ministry can be how you
tip the waitress
Ministry can be I work at ubereats and
he works at a print shop and we honor
and love everybody especially the least
of these
that's Ministry too
right and unfortunately
churches don't have
um some of the same protections that um
you can't say certain things in a
workplace you can't just demean people
in a workplace
right or you can't say I'm praying for
you because and then spill a bunch of
you know gossip and whatever poison on
you
right and so it might be time to say
okay we're gonna we're still gonna do
ministry quote unquote we're still going
to be
people who espouse our faith values to
everyone all over the place
but we're gonna do it in a business
we're gonna do it as a small business
we're gonna do it cutting grass
and we're gonna do it as counselors
we're gonna do it in it here's I'm
saying change your picture of what of
what your core vision for your life is
change the environment change the
picture of that and at least spend time
entertaining it might not be where you
land but at least spend time
entertaining it because right now you
keep sticking your hand back in the bag
and getting bit by the same rattlesnake
and you're so mad at the rattlesnake and
it's just looking at you going that's
what I do I bite people like you
yeah
so give me an example of of a thing a
church did
um so the church my husband just left I
was
I was an office manager there and um the
church just let this one guy
she wasn't even on staff just
um
he just let that let this man like uh
call our the current pass at that time
we've gone through two passes in like
six months
but let him just totally attack them
personally verbally abusing them
um just yelling at them
it's this guy who's been with the church
for like 20 plus years
and then he uh
I'm the type of person who I like to
follow the rules I see things as black
and white nerd just kidding he's still
kidding okay and he kept trying to like
not follow the rules in the office and
everybody else has to and I was the only
one to like stand up to him and say hey
like I'm creating these processes for a
reason me to follow these and then I
became a Target and then he him and his
friend of the church who they both
had some sort of leadership they weren't
paid called me a Nazi they called me
weak they called me pathetic they told
me and my co-worker to shut up
um and the church
didn't do anything about it until I
wrote
two letters
to the you know the leadership team
about it didn't hear anything or current
pastor at the time ended up leaving my
husband
it was hard he was in a really hard spot
because he like loved his youth group
and wanted to keep working there
he was in a very easy spot
if people at a work environment where me
and my wife are both employed if
somebody's treating my wife like that
that doesn't end well for anybody
yeah and I will as Jesus says imma dust
my sandals off and as the great Jay-Z
says I'm gonna brush my shoulders off
I'm out bye Felicia we go
yeah see what I'm saying
yeah
and like it's it's a
it's shameful and by the way that is
happening at churches all across the
country it's happening in elementary
schools and at school board meetings one
or two or three absolutely power starved
maniacal idiots is ruining it for
everybody and until institutions like
churches like schools like universities
stand up and say get out
what's going to happen is they're going
to drive out every young passionate
person
who is interested in caring about people
loving young people loving old people
loving everybody whether it's through an
education whether it's through Public
Service whether it's through their faith
tradition they're going to run them out
because their leadership is cowards
cowards
and I'm sorry that happened to you
yeah and they the church under the they
got a different interim pastor hold on
hold on hold on hold on
you keep wanting to talk about your
ex-boyfriend
you're married now oh oh you're married
now you you wanna you used to date
somebody and you keep going to Facebook
to see who they're with even though
you're married
yeah and then you heard you had a kid
and you want to go find out what his kid
looked like
because at one point a long time ago you
imagined yourself having kids with him
and I'll tell you I I I wouldn't give
that church another thought
and they've showed you what they think
of you they've shown you what they think
of love and accountability and Justice
and doing right by people
yeah and they've shown their cowardice
by hiding behind two loudmouth morons
who probably have nice checkbooks
yeah or like to wield scripture like um
like a like us
like a sword
instead of like a
manual like a like a
narrative operating guide for how to
love the least of these
yeah it says widows and orphans and
hungry people not you Nazi right
yeah so dude if you went to a grocery
store and every time you walked in they
were like ah here comes the Nazi witch
ah and they threw fruit at you you would
just leave and you're like they're nuts
I want you to treat this situation the
same
and maybe this is the time and I've get
I'm I'm just picking this out of the
Moon don't overthink this okay but maybe
this is the time when you rethink sit
down and ask your husband husband I
won't bite your head off I'll be honest
I mean I'll
I will oh I I just need some honest
truth
am I too overbearing about rules do I
hide do they protect me do I hide do I
hang on to them too tightly and he might
go in a flinching way yeah right maybe
this is that season
and maybe you tell them hey you hung on
at that church too long you broke my
heart for a while you chose the youth
group over me
yeah and you need to deal with that in
your marriage and it's real easy when
you get that Crossways that you're gonna
blame the church you're gonna get mad at
these guys but really that's just that's
just misdirected anger you're really mad
at your husband you're heartbroken
did he ever confront that guy that was
coming by the office and causing all the
problems
start there
there is no but
you start there
he he did confront the church nope nope
okay
if a man walks into the place where me
and my wife both work
and he sends my wife out in tears
because he was calling her names just
for her doing her job
he'll deal directly with me
and I'm not saying that in some Beefcake
Flex off I'm not talking about we're
gonna do a pose down I'm gonna fight him
in a church parking lot what I'm saying
is I'm gonna go have that conversation
and your husband didn't do that and
there's part of you inside wondering are
am I worth am I worth rescuing
and you got to start there
leave the church out of this stuff
there's idiots everywhere every
organization on the planet has
extraordinary wonderful people and
idiots
and occasionally the idiots run the
place I also know by the way there's
some really extraordinary churches out
there doing amazing things
right okay but the question you have to
ask is husband why
why
when I looked over my shoulder why
weren't you standing there
when this guy was in there yelling when
this him and his knuckleheaded buddy
were in there hollering at me and saying
these things about me
why weren't you at their front door of
their homes
why aren't you on the phone with them
am I worth so little
that's where you start that's a that's
that's a
girl with a broken heart
you're not crazy and you're not you're
not misguided and I'm not overly zealous
sorry this happened
sorry it happened
for many of us
I am including myself here
it's very hard
to wind up
occupation work the HR part of
employment
and my faith and my faith Journey
and my love of teaching
and my love of helping hurting people
and people who throw grenades just
because that gives them the only little
like shred of power they have in their
miserable tiny little lives
hard and so
professional Ministry is not for
everybody
just not and that's all right
Formula One racing isn't for everybody
janitorial services isn't for everybody
only a select few who can do Excellence
when nobody's watching
this is you and your husband go on a
quick weekend retreat you'll ask each
other you ask yourselves
what do we bring to this
where were you hon where were you
and give him permission to speak into
you because I'm sure he's got some
thoughts on you too
and then ask yourselves what does
Ministry look like for us not in a
church
what does employment look like for us
somewhere not in a church and at least
just sit with that for a while it might
not be where you land but at least sit
with it
because right now this is one two Church
three
there's a pattern like quickly emerging
and when we see trend lines when we see
patterns often let's just stop what
we're doing right now so the pattern
doesn't get the trend doesn't get any
any worse maybe we do something
completely different and see if that
reverses the trend
so sorry this happened to you JC
institutions churches colleges
elementary schools
school boards
if you do not immediately start standing
up to the idiots on each side of the
aisle on each side of on on every side
of the socioeconomic scale if you don't
start standing up to the few loud
lunatics
You're Gonna Lose everybody
they're just going to take their ball
and go home